foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
David Pac-Man he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta man they go along with
homosexuality hold on Buddy
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog but another baby doesn't
because he's a logical thinking and
they're controlled by the darkness of
David Pac-Man
now
[Music]
David Patman he is
[Music]
David Patman is
[Music]
a baby girl
David Pac-Man he is
David you're not here to communicate I
really appreciate you coming on I'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're acting like an image you're
asking bizarre questions
and you're wasting my time I'm preaching
at home all right
goodbye
[Music]
all men who are progressive
[Music]
they are weak people and why having
people aren't it doesn't even make them
they're in suits I know of a guy who
fits that bill of aggressive with
political will but David pectin shall
see your political knowledge sign up for
a membership now for the bonus show
that's best who's the current president
of the United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'd rather not answer that how's that
categorization
[Music]
I've been growing with one huge pepper
all summer
it's time to pluck it
[Music]
[Music]
there's a story
[Music]
that makes me wanna sing that catchy
catches
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
said okay
okay now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right well another debate today that
could relate to
who gets to decide who has won a state
in 2024. now that's kind of unusual
language right you might be saying sir
you're making me tear up what do you
mean who gets to dis the voters decide
don't they well yes the voters should
decide this may be radical but my view
is
the candidate that gets the most votes
in a state
should get the electoral votes of that
state that's my view okay
in Pennsylvania with Doug mastrianos
candidacy and in Georgia with Brian
Kemps although let's let's be honest
Kemp did stop short of straight up
stealing it for Trump in fact he You
could argue he was part of the reason
Trump didn't steal Georgia uh but things
can change very very quickly with these
uh extremist Republicans Georgia is
another one of these states that could
be the Difference Maker in 2024
and we need someone there who is going
to play essentially no role in
determining who won as governor of that
state and we are talking about Stacy
Abrams the Democratic Challenger in
Georgia and the incumbent governor
Republican Brian Kemp we are moments
away from the start of this debate now
how is this race looking I don't want to
be the bearer of bad news
it's not looking great okay so on
average right now as you can see here
the incumbent Governor Brian Kemp
leading by an avarage of Five Points 51
to 46 and indeed with 51 percent he
would be over that 50 Mark but this is
you know we don't know the these polls
are based first of all part of plus nine
is from a right wing leaning
Paul the Trafalgar group if you don't
include that it's more like plus three
and a half that's that's number one but
number two all of the likely voter
models
used in this polling are not accounting
for and here understand the word I'm
going to be using
the possibility
not the certainty the possibility of Roe
v Wade really motivating people to get
out and vote for Democrats in a way that
the likely voter models and employed by
pollsters are not accounting for that's
the possibility
very important word so this is where we
are right now
when she's uh on
Stacy Abrams is really good at this
debating thing here is a part of a
debate from
oh was this was this 2018 now I don't
remember yeah I believe this was from
2018. check this out the question is why
are you encouraging people to break the
law for you in this election Mr Kemp you
are very aware that I know the laws of
Georgia when it comes to voting in fact
I am one of the foremost experts in the
state on expansion of voting rights and
I have never in my life asked for anyone
who is not legally eligible to vote to
be able to cast a ballot what I've asked
for is that you allow those who are
legally eligible to vote to allow them
to cast their ballots and in fact we
took you to court in 2016 and a federal
judge said that you illegally canceled
34 000 registrations you use the exact
same system the exact match system that
is under dispute right now now I realize
that in the next response you're going
to say that it's a function of my
organization because your tendency is to
blame everyone else for the mistakes
that you make my responsibility as a
leader is to see a problem and try to
solve it when I saw that we had eight
hundred thousand unregistered people of
color in the state of Georgia I started
an organization that has reached into
every County and increased those
registrations when I saw the people
being lawfully denied the right to vote
I worked to make certain that we held
you accountable and as the next governor
of Georgia I will continue to do my job
to make certain that every legally
eligible vote that gets cast gets
counted yeah she's uh she's quite good
she's quite good so I am very much
looking forward to this debate uh anyone
can have a good day and a bad day and if
we've learned anything covering debate
after debate so far this election season
it's that sometimes you expect people to
do terribly and they are able to survive
Herschel Walker sometimes you expect
people to do really really great and
they don't do so well that includes
Rafael Warnock that includes Mark Kelly
that includes Tim Ryan so we will see
what things look like in just a few
moments also want to remind you that
tomorrow night uh incumbent Florida
Republican senator Marco Rubio will be
debating Democratic Challenger Val
demings I will be live with that
um and it's going to be probably also a
very interesting debate okay let's
welcome a few people I do want to say
thanks to Andrew Culp and Jason
sickmeyer who just gifted two
subscriptions on my website
joinpakman.com also very important Alice
maravillas as well as office drummer
office drummer whose twitch stream I've
recommended re-upping twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at four where
are we over here is it over here or no
there it is uh putting us at four folks
let's get to 100 and we can use the
coupon code big voting22 on my website
[Music]
um
oh by the way guys
there has been an explosion in
anti-Semitism targeting me in the last
two and a half hours because I correctly
and accurately described Kanye West's
recent rant as the most anti-Semitic
rant I've seen Short of actual Nazis and
I'm already seeing I don't know like
this comment so you feel personally
attacked by what Kanye said it's it's
that has nothing to do with anything
okay mods let's just keep an eye out on
things that could be
um an invasion of anti-Semitism here
because judging by the emails I've been
getting since this video went live a
couple hours ago we might be very very
much in for it tonight okay
um
yeah everybody everybody just be
prepared for that also thanks to rated R
Roy for the twitch Prime subscription
you are number five and we've got files
opening and all sorts of different stuff
okay let's get to a couple of
interesting clips that I have here for
you
Herschel Walker may be pointing to
possible time travel as the explanation
for
this completely insane abortion related
Scandal the new line from Herschel
Walker is okay fine the woman who claims
I I urged her to get an abortion and
paid for it she is the mother of one of
my of my kids and yes I did send her a
700 check and yes that is my signature
on the check but I sent that
because she's the mother of my child
to help her the problem is it was years
before the child was ultimately born is
time traveled the explanation maybe
let's take a listen this is still alive
because she's the mother of my child so
you're going to see me on check of
somebody giving a check so that I'm
saying it's a lot do you know what this
700. I have no idea what that can be for
is that your signature though let me see
it could be it doesn't matter whether
it's my signature or not yes that's my
check that's his check so listen guys it
doesn't matter that he sent the 700
dollar check at a time when his eventual
child didn't exist
he clearly suspected that even though
that pregnancy was being terminated at
some point in the future that very same
relationship would lead to a pregnancy
and a kid and he was just sending the
money ahead of time how does that sound
believable is that a possible
explanation time travel could that be it
okay then the very same Herschel Walker
uh was asked about the badge thing and
he's insisting that the badge he pulled
out during the debate the other day was
real I guess and his explanation is
totally incoherent let's talk about
I don't know if you have
badge with you but a lot of people are
wondering what was that badge do you
have that is legit it's a legit badge he
claims that's a badge that I was given
by a police officer and I was given to
him by a police officer you have it I I
carry it with me all the time it's not
it's a real badge it's not a fake bad it
is a real bad who gave you the badge
this badge is from uh this bad and I
have badges all over the All Over
Georgia is it possible that Walker is
such a good undercover officer for the
FBI and a dozen police departments that
they just don't even know it is that a
possibility even from Chatham County I
have wait wait I have from Chatham
County which is the county which is the
county
which is accounted from uh you know I
have it upside down make sure it's right
which is accounted from where Senator
one night is from I have an honorary
Sheriff band why would you carry that
around you know so anyway now he says
it's an honorary share of Spanish this
is of no value you know how like
sometimes
this is a crazy analogy but this is
where we are in American politics
you know how sometimes when a kid goes
on a plane like especially in the
pre-911 days
the pilot would give them like some
wings that they could wear
you might be shocked to hear that that
doesn't put you any closer to actually
being a real pilot that that an actual
pilot handed you those wings it doesn't
make you any it doesn't make you a real
pilot
um
this is kind of similar
County where is this one from this is
from my hometown this is from Johnson
County from the sheriff from Johnson
County which is a legit badge everyone
can make fun but this bad give me the
right if let me finish if anything
happened in this counter I have the
right to work with the police and
getting things done okay did you guys
notice that he just said something that
doesn't mean anything if anything
happens in this County
I have the right and it's like you know
they talk about all these people are
claiming rights that aren't really
rights I have the right
to work with the police what does that
mean
doesn't mean anything doesn't have any
meaning whatsoever
um this guy is uh sadly very very very
disconnected from reality and it doesn't
bring me any pleasure to mention that
okay
uh super chats coming in no no super
chats coming in all right that's okay
we're gonna continue we have a lot of
other things to look at here
um oh you know how the Wright loves to
talk about the left
indoctrinating children here is an ad
for
a horrible right-wing indoctrination of
children check this out pay parents and
grandparents as we wait to see what he
was for president Trump Mike Huckabee's
education company wants to help your
kids learn all about President Trump's
greatest achievements during his first
term yeah Mike Huckabee wants to help
your kids learn
it's already dicey
about Trump's greatest achievements
I don't know guys this and there seems
to be a page about The Apprentice that's
why we're giving away the kid's guide to
president Trump for free this is giving
it away you don't even have to pay
people would pay fun kids guide will
help your kids to understand everything
president Trump has already accomplished
without this they wouldn't be able to
understand it but with this they'll
they'll be able to understand it for
America what's more it's part of a very
special gift bundle that includes a free
Kids magazine and a free video Lesson
too to learn more and order this free
gift bundle just visit
freetrumpguide.com wow
freetrumpguide.com let me let me see if
I can pull that up freetrumpguide.com
see what the deal is with that
yeah here it is
help your kids learn the truth about
President Trump and celebrate America
with a free patriotic gift bundle
the kids guide to Trump and then the
celebrate our freedom thing
hmm
let's see what Huckabee says hi this is
Mike Huckabee
uh-huh
glitchy website
let's try it again
hi this is Mike Huckabee well
cheers
super glitchy
I'll refresh once I don't know
hi this is Mike Huckabee yeah
I think it's done
all right well
there it is that's the free and by the
way guys they're against the
indoctrination of children just so you
know
very very much strongly against it they
don't want any of it thanks to Matt
jenkinson Andrew Sousa and Stefan
thunason who just signed up on my
website
joinpakman.com they are new members
867 and 8. also thanks to cubaimus 2021
for the twitch subscription you are new
member number nine today you remember
number nine very much appreciate that I
would love it I would love it if you and
I do mean you
signed up on my website
joinpakman.com it's quick it's easy and
you can use the coupon code big voting22
to get a horrifyingly embarrassing
discount super chats Larry says hey
David hope you're doing well but special
agent Walker Texas Ranger wants to see
your ID don't worry you can show him one
of those Toys R Us police badges to win
them over yeah at what point does the
Herschel Walker thing become
impersonating a police officer
best part of the flower is green debate
flowers really said Republicans come up
to me with tears in their eyes saying
please get rid of Marjorie Taylor Green
Oh that I've got to see hold on
flowers tears I didn't I didn't see that
see here
here oh hold on a second did he really
do it that would be amazing maybe he
watches the show
oh were anybody know the time code
hold on
flowers tears
oh 9 10. okay hold on let's see this
this I have to see
talk too it doesn't matter if it's a
republican independent or democrat I've
talked to everybody
everybody that I talk to Republicans
come up to me every day with tears in
their eyes
oh that I don't know if that is the most
genius trolling in the history of
American politics
or if he's just being serious that is
unbelievable let me I'm just going to go
back a few seconds that's a genius I've
talked to everybody
and everybody that I talk to Republicans
come up to me every day with tears in
their eyes saying please
get rid of Marjorie Taylor green
this guy I I really like Marcus flowers
I thought he absolutely crushed the
debate and we covered it on the podcast
today but somehow I didn't see this clip
this guy's a genius sure sure sure
yeah she doesn't represent us she truly
doesn't and I've heard this time and
time again they come up to him with
tears in their eyes that is that is just
perfect really really nice I like Marcus
flowers even more uh uh at this point
uh free Trump guide giving away toilet
paper to the Maga masses I know well
said if you look at the terms and
conditions of Huckabee's program I
believe it actually is 20 bucks a month
after the first month oh I'm sure it's
not really free indefinitely
sir I know the competition is fierce but
in your view who gets the title of
biggest Trump suck up
I mean JP Mandel AKA JD Vance is a
pretty big suck up
but
there's I mean I don't know Marjorie
Taylor green is certainly one
um there's a lot of big big big Trump
suck UPS it's hard to pick it really is
difficult to pick just one
uh okay we are moments away moments away
from the start of this extraordinarily
important debate between Stacy Abrams
and Brian Kemp oh I have one little
recommendation for you guys I really
don't do this often I've done it you
know a dozen times or so if I have like
a newsletter or some kind of thing that
I think is really worthwhile I will
recommend it okay there is a newsletter
I really want to recommend to you guys
today
a friend of mine Steve schlafman now has
a newsletter called light waves and it
is really really really good the
articles are like seven eight minutes to
read
Steve used to be a venture capitalist in
the city then he became a Coach and he's
a writer these are I I don't I find the
Articles really really good and they're
just about like life I don't even know
how else to describe it so when people
um ask me what sort of stuff other than
books do I read you know I read Nick
majuli's newsletter uh I like Barry
rithold's newsletter for for personal
finance Steves is really really good so
you can find this at schlaf.com that's C
uh s sorry sorry let me go back to the
beginning this has nothing to do with
Matt schlapp by the way yeah very
important
s-c-h-l-a-f dot Co
and it's free I'm not selling you
anything here it's just it's just free
and tell Steve I sent you and it's a
really really great thing all right so
check that out I think a lot of people
will very very much like it
uh okay other oh wow memberships are
dumping um Wendy cyrna just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
10 Christian misky just signed up and
his new member number 11 and then also
caddy caddy ah just signed up via twitch
Prime and his new member number 12.
really appreciate the support and all
that this insane debate schedule that
we've been maintaining
is all all
um related to the support for membership
that we have seen from so many different
great people all right do we want to do
a couple voicemails before the debate
starts let's try uh it's always a little
dicey
um let's see what I've got from the
standpoint of voicemails here
uh
uh man I don't know
hey David my name is David too I'm also
Jewish God Bless America
I just disgraced by Kanye I thought he
was the best artist of all time
I still think he is but he's so
disgraceful now what he's done
what he's saying but it just reminds me
I spend time in prison
this reminds me of the
uh
some of the Black Culture in prison oh
yeah the eggman's talked about how there
was some anti the Eggman has served time
in a federal facility and he said there
was some anti-Semitism among the black
folks listen we
lots of groups lots of minority groups
also discriminate against other minority
groups and we know that the Prop 8
situation in California
was partially defeated because of
homophobia homophobia
homophobia in the black community and
there's some anti-Semitism in the black
community as well we've talked about
anti-trans sentiment among elements of
the gay community you know all these
things exist and they're all they're all
horrible that's uh that's for damn sure
uh let's see other voicemails coming in
uh what else do I have
Pac-Man what is good oh this is the San
Antonio troll he usually calls in to
criticize me for things I never said
that he probably heard on a different
show would you
um I'm calling to talk about something
that is a luxury belief a luxury belief
okay familiar with this
thank you and a lot of your audience
a wealthy white and probably in college
um suffer from so let me give you a
quick example
so you will sit there with your high
income job in your high income
neighborhood and say maybe
um white people have privileged too much
from society therefore we should not uh
you know we should prioritize other
people who aren't white from heaven
easy for you to say like you get to feel
good
so on Twitter they're like oh my God
you're so well Pac-Man oh my God you're
so here's the thing now you don't
um let's say benefits belief like that
or you are impacted by
you still have your job you still have
income you still have your own whatever
it is I'm not impacted by what my
opinion I don't even know what that
means but other I'm not even really sure
what the what's the claim that's being
made here exactly
tied into the social ladders you are are
impacted by it the left and you guys one
of the things you preach about a lot to
find the okay you and your high income
neighborhood I think that he meant to
say defund the police and he choked I
have never advocated for defund the
police so again this is one of those
examples where he's attacking me for a
belief I don't hold
is he trying to call a different host
Maybe
are impacted by a rising crime
um whereas people in low income area a
luxury belief happen I think liberals
have a problem and it's why Democrats
are losing the working class yeah a lot
of uh Hispanic voters and they're also
I'm a Hispanic voter what are you
talking about losing
um uh the plot big time on crime all
right anyway
that's the San Antonio troll his move is
attack me for things I didn't say
thanks to motion 802 for the twitch
Prime subscription your number 13 today
which I very very much appreciate and we
have a target of 100 today the absolute
best thing we all can do right now
because we need strong independent media
is to get those memberships on my
website I will show you how easy it is
Boom look at this joinpakman.com you can
do monthly or yearly it's your choice
you hit the sign up button I know that
the coupon code there says big voting 22
but let me just show you a different
coupon code which is Obama Obama and
then the price just comes right down
they
when you're famous they just let you do
it you enter the coupon code and you
just get the discount and all of you are
famous to me because you are viewers and
that's a really really exciting thing
let's see who else we've got here
dropping in a voicemail oh thanks to
robbie82 for the twitch Prime
subscription I very much appreciate that
um let's see what else I have oh I do
have a a voicemail from Whitney
is working nice thing to make like a
look that looks normal the people just
agree that's normal just because it's
like oh well uh there would be nothing
about your face that like oh well maybe
that person has a cold like it resembles
like the same features as somebody who
would have like maybe a stuffy nose or a
thyroid problem or uh what
you know uh
what's really wrong with your face oh
man all right I'm going to move on from
that it's uh it's pretty pretty wacky
stuff other uh super chats coming in
will says hey David haven't been on
stream in a bit glad to see you were
still streaming very strongly any chance
you can shout out my daughter Arie or
Ari who has a birthday this Saturday
absolutely shout out to Arie I assume
it's Airy short for Arielle uh let's get
to the debate which is starting very
very strongly right now
uh
yeah with wrbl in Columbus Georgia for
complete rules on today's debate please
visit the Atlanta website
atlantapressclub.org debates to start
the debate each candidate will be asked
two questions candidates have 60 seconds
to answer each question Chuck Williams
you get the first question of Stacy
Abrams thank you Donna Miss Abrams
public opinion polls in our state show
support for the right to abortion
Medicaid expansion and banning assault
weapons you're on the side of public
opinion in each of these issues yet you
are behind in almost every poll why
first of all thank you so much for
having me and I appreciate the
opportunity to address the communities
of Georgia
the reason people are on my side are
because because I'm on the right side of
history and on the right side of the
issues but we also know that polls are
snapshot the question is who are they
taking a picture of when I'm going
across this state the people I'm talking
to are excited about this election but
they also know that they're often left
out of the conversation students who
have found themselves
oh God what just happened did we just
lose it
what on Earth was that
off air
what the heck it went it lasted a minute
and then it bailed
do we have any other streams
what is happening that was crazy
what the heck off air
what the hell is going on
uh watch live
where is
this is just an article
the live feed is having issues
oh God you got to be kidding me
GBP
lie oh every oh it's everywhere oh okay
so it's not just okay everybody's having
the issue okay
um let's see
let's see if we can get yeah it's off
air wow
wow wow wow all right I guess all we can
do is wait for it to come back it does
it seems like all the streams the live
feed is dead it's dead everywhere okay
all right everybody it's not an issue
here okay the stream appears to have
died everywhere
it appears to okay Reuters live Kemp
Abrams let's see
um
no that says off air as well
there's YouTube
still off air
uh okay hold on here we go I got us guys
oh boy this look at this save your
question for Shane Hazel Mr Hazel
Georgia seems to be struggling right now
in dealing with how to legally take on
the issue of cannabis in the state what
do you think needs to be done here how
should Georgia address the issues
surrounding marijuana I guess that I
guess a perfect question for a
Libertarian
um we believe that cannabis is a plant
that grows from Earth naturally and the
hubris that the federal government has
shown in making a schedule one drug
while also holding patents on it is one
of those things where we find it
somewhat laughable and it is it is a
right of people it is medicine it is
something that we can add to our
industry here in Georgia and really
displace a lot of what comes in from
outside of Georgia this is a huge win
for Georgia we have a great agricultural
sector we can grow two bumper crops of
cannabis every year the idea that is
still on illegal and that Brian Kemp has
talked about this and tweeted about it
as it is a good thing when we make
cannabis busts and cannabis bust only is
a is a real sign that the government in
Georgia is using it for the present
industrial complex for the the law
enforcement complex to go after
communities that would like to see
freedom in this area so it's a right
that's how we see it as Libertarians
right thank you very much
you may you have a rebuttal yeah I would
just like to make sure people at home
know that I have been doing exactly what
I've told them I would do when I was
campaigning for governor and now that I
am your Governor we have been going
after street gangs and drug cartels so
the things that we're tweeting out there
is when our great men and women in law
enforcement are are making drug burst
bust not from recreational use it's a
plan of things
but but that's what my focus is on all
right thank you isn't this guy horrible
all right please ask a question of Stacy
Abrams and Miss Abrams in 2018 you
didn't concede defeat to Governor Kemp
and you talked to systemic problems with
the state selection system this election
do you commit to accept the outcome of
the vote regardless of what it shows and
do you stand by your use of words like
rigged four years ago to describe the
state selection system
in 2018 I began my speech on November
16th acknowledging that Governor Kemp
had won the election I then proceeded to
lay out in grave detail the challenges
faced by voters under his leadership as
Secretary of State including the 10 plus
two who were arrested in Quitman Georgia
because they had the temerity to use
absentee ballots I told the story of
students who were denied access to the
right to vote even though they had duly
registered 80 000 complaints that come
in by that day and it took four years of
federal investigation in a lawsuit that
was the longest running voting rights
lawsuit in the state's history in recent
history that proved us right now we
didn't win every single claim but we
forced massive changes to the election
laws and unfortunately Brian Kemp and
Brad rafsenberger have decided to
restore their greatest hits just today a
homeless woman was denied the right to
vote in Forsyth County because she could
not she did not receive a provisional
ballot because she had been challenged
as Governor I intend to stand up for the
right to vote I will always acknowledge
the outcome of Elections but I will
never deny access to every voter because
that is the responsibility of every
American to defend the right to vote
thank you Brian Kemp rebuttal 30 seconds
well I would just say uh the Miss Abrams
is going to do a lot of attacking of my
record tonight because she doesn't want
to talk about her own record in 2018 in
the governor's race we had the largest
African-American turnout in the country
she said that Senate Bill 202 our recent
elections Integrity act we passed two
years ago would be suppressive in Jim
Crow 2.0 just this past May in our
primaries we again had record turnout in
the Republican primary and the
Democratic Primary in Georgia it's easy
to vote and hard to cheat I'd like to
add just a second here as the
libertarian 30 seconds although you will
push for people to have access to going
to the polls and voting you're not
pushing valid access this is a huge a
huge impression for people like the
third parties the people that want to
get their people on the ballot we have I
think 20 Democrats 20 Republicans in
this state of Georgia that leaves 60
percent of people in Georgia
unrepresented by ballot access laws that
both of them support 30 seconds Miss
Abrams actually to correct Mr Hazel I
co-sponsored legislation to expand
ballot access because I agree with you
that third parties should have better
access to the right to vote in the state
of Georgia I co-sponsored it with with
one of our Independents in the state
legislation you never heard of it but
let's be clear about ballot access and
voter access Brian Kemp was the
Secretary of State and he has
assiduously denied access to the right
to vote we know that the right to vote
is the only way that we can make the
changes we need in the state the only
way we can make the changes we need in
this country whether it's access to the
right to an abortion the ability to take
care of our families we need a governor
who believes in access to the right to
vote and not in voter suppression which
is the Hallmark of Brian Kemp's
leadership thank you very much with all
due respect I was called out I would
like to just the record reflect because
my time as Secretary of State I'm the
person that created the online voter
registration system in state where any
Georgian can vote register to vote 24
hours a day seven days a week so for
someone to say that we have been
suppressive in our state when we've seen
turnout increase over the years
including with minorities like African
Americans Latinos and others is simply
not true and again miss Abrams is going
to lie about my record because she
doesn't want to talk about her own all
right we're going to move on here we're
going to move on here Mr Hazel Jennifer
your question for Brian Kemp Governor
Kemp several hospitals in medical
centers across the state have announced
or gone through with plans to close
their doors leaving a gap in care and a
reduction in services at a time when our
health care workers are already
suffering from burnout from increased
demand and workloads many are now facing
care that will be delayed or unavailable
while our state's capital will soon have
only one level one Trauma Center what
will you do to ensure Georgians have
access to critical health care services
and hospitals nothing well I would just
remind voters that home there's also
hospitals being built across this state
and new options for people for Health
Care look the AMC situation was
something that was thrown on a lot of
political leaders including me but
instead of complaining about it and
doing the blame game I went and worked
with Fulton County with DeKalb County
with Democrats to come up with a
solution to put State resources into
Grady to help make sure people have the
access and the care that they need in
our state and I'm committed to
continuing to do that in the future
all right Shane I'm sorry uh Chuck you
get the final question to Shane Hazel
Mr Hazel you ran for congress in 2018.
that was just four years ago you ran as
a republican you got less than 30
percent of the vote in the Republican
primary what happened between then and
now that made you a Libertarian oh I uh
I actually came back to my my roots as a
Libertarian uh we believe in Freedom we
saw what the Republican party was we saw
what the Democratic party was they are
forcing coercion no matter what they
talk about is forcing coercion whether
it's certificate of Need for hospitals
whether it is taking guns away from
law-abiding citizens it is always
forcing coercion at the point of a gun
from the Democrats and Republicans to
look at life through consent the eyes of
hey we can all have transactions we do
it every day in the private sector 99.9
of us go throughout our day without
raping people without murdering people
without pointing guns at people to take
their property this is the libertarian
delusional stuff that I interviewed a
professor about the other day period
that's why I became a Libertarian this
is why we're going to send this thing
into a runoff and if people were really
looking for something to change you'd
vote libertarian you'd send a message to
both of these parties because these one
of these people will most likely be the
executive in a rig system that you want
to be more free thank you that concludes
the first round of the debate the
candidates will now ask a question to
each of their opponents candidates will
have 30 seconds to ask the question 60
seconds to respond and the candidate who
asked the questions will have 30 seconds
for a rebuttal by random selection Brian
Kemp you may ask the first question to
Stacy Abrams well thank you very much
um as many people know I have over a
hundred sheriffs endorsing my campaign
uh several which are Democrats so much
for Miss Abrams tonight is how many
Democrats or how many sheriffs Statewide
have publicly endorsed your campaign
Mr Kemp what you are attempting to do is
continue the lie that you've told so
many times I think you believe it's the
truth I support law enforcement and did
so for 11 years worked closely with the
sheriff's Association I'm probably the
only person standing here who's ever
actually written a sop for police
department when I was working for the
City of Atlanta but I have two brothers
one who has committed crimes and I want
his victims to be able to call the
police and get the help they need and
I've always supported that right but I
have another brother who is faced being
pulled over for driving while black when
he was coming back from his job as a
social worker unlike you I don't have
the luxury of relying on slogans to
describe my position on Public Safety I
believe that we need safety and Justice
because I love both of my brothers and
like most Georgians I lead a complicated
life where we need access to help but we
also need to know that we are safe from
racial violence while you may not have
had that experience too many people I
know have and that is why I will always
stand up for making certain that safety
and Justice are the conversations we're
having in Georgia and the delivery we
have as the next governor of Georgia
she's really thank you for 30 seconds Mr
Kim well well I would just tell people
that look I support safety and justice
but miss Abrams refused to answer the
question so I'll let you know that the
answer is zero no sheriffs are endorsing
her Statewide because of her stances on
wanting to defund the police eliminate
cash bail and serving on the boards of
organizations like the Margaret Casey
Foundation that supports and gives
grants to organizations that are
promoting the defund the police movement
If he if I may respond because he
actually lied there yes I do have the
support of sheriffs but unlike Mr Kemp I
do not make it my plan to list every
person who supports me I have the
support of sheriffs I have the support
of Advocates and the support of victims
I have the support of those who want to
be treated fairly in our system I have
to have conversations with the entirety
of Georgia I don't have the luxury of
being a part of a good old boys club
where we don't focus on the needs of our
people and that is why my mission has
been to put out very concrete plans
explaining how I will serve Justice how
I will serve safety and how I I will
serve the citizens of the state of
Georgia 30 seconds Brian Campbell well
look I would just tell people I know
Miss Abrams is upset and mad because
these are things that she said this is
not me is this like an angry black woman
type comment in interviews that she's
done and she's sitting on organizations
that you can go look at the facts
yourself and that's why the men and
women in law enforcement wanted Governor
that is going to stand with them who has
been with them not only to have their
back but also stand shoulder to shoulder
on things like civil unrest and going
after I know she's mad she is thank you
very much Stacy Abrams you get the next
question for Shane Hazel Mr Hazel
Republicans and Democrats have raised
the alarm over the rise in the Chinese
Communist Party backed companies
purchasing American Farmland to date
they've purchased more than one million
Acres of Farmland in the state of
Georgia would you agree with Mike Pompeo
that allowing those purchases in the
state of Georgia a sign of Madness and
would you be concerned about the
National Security implications of the
Chinese Communist Party purchasing this
land with the support of the state of
Georgia
I see the setup for this question I
understand why it was projected in me
um as Libertarians we believe that you
own your property and that the state
can't take it away from you and can't
sell it or can't determine who you sell
it to the CCP obviously which is going
through some its own internal unrest
right now uh I believe is probably
purchasing this with things like Central
Bank digital dollars in Yuan which are
also coming down to a a critical nature
where people are in Uprising he's like I
know why you asked me this question and
she's like I do too based on the first
30 seconds of your answer be accepting
Fiat CCP yuan in Georgia as a actual
currency it's about as good as the U.S
currency the fiat currency that we're
about to have hoisted on us in terms of
a cbdc I'm not going to tell you or
anybody else as Governor how or who to
sell your property to and I imagine that
in the end the free market will work
itself out thank you Stacey Abrams 30
seconds the state of Georgia is watching
our Farmland be purchased by the Chinese
Communist party and while that is not
normally a conversation that we have it
is something that we should be concerned
about agriculture is our number one
industry and Georgia has 13 military
installations the fact that the state of
Georgia is working with the Chinese
Communist Party using one of their
technologies that both Donald Trump and
Joe Biden have warned is very much a
national security threat it should be of
great concern to every Georgian this is
not about being concerned simply about
who's owning the land but it's about how
much access to our information they have
because of that state thank you Shane
Hazel you may ask your question of Stacy
Abrams yeah I'd agree with you the
military-industrial complex is a big
problem it is and the fact that we have
people trying to come here I don't know
get a get a back door into our our
military I think one of the things we
should be talking about as Georgians and
as Executives is the defend the guard
act where our military has been used
very I don't know haphazardly around the
world to go and take resources from the
Middle East is this a question now in Mr
Hazel your question yeah this is my
question to who to Stacy oh we've
already switched gears yeah my my
question to you I'm sorry it's okay I
have hearing problems guys
um my question to you is I mentioned
cbdc's as the executive of Georgia when
we come into a cbdc from the Federal
Reserve will you as the executive
except
these the cccp style currency I believe
that the conversation about currency is
a complicated one and part of the
challenge we have is how these how this
currency is transmitted the very real
security threats with digital currency
the hacking and Mining of that digital
currency should concern all Georgians
governor of Georgia I will work very
closely with the Federal Reserve but
also with the innovators and the
entrepreneurs who do see an opportunity
but before we take a step forward that
can put us at risk our responsibility is
to understand the complexity of what is
happening with these transactions and as
exciting as it is we also know it's
deeply problematic when we do not have
the adequate safeguards in place that's
one of the reasons I've raised concerns
about WeChat and about the purchase of
Farmland but what we know overall is
that we need a governor who's conversant
in these issues who understands that for
example in the state of Georgia we have
access to 3.5 billion dollars in
American currency that could be
delivered tomorrow to save our hospitals
and to save our lives but our current
governor has refused to accept those
dollars my intention is to do what's
best for the state of Georgia every
single day Shane Hazel she's really
knowledgeable about so many issues got
us into the mess that we are in right
now because of a centralized fiat
currency it will be absolutely worthless
be dangling carrots in front of the
governor in front of the executives in
front of the legislature to do exactly
what their mandates are if they are
mandating that they take the property of
people then they will do it if they want
to invade your homes your privacy your
businesses they will do it because of
cbdc's all right Stacey Abrams please
ask your question to Brian Kemp
absolutely
Mr Kemp under your leadership there is
currently a 100 Year gap between
minority-owned businesses and majority
owned businesses although minorities
comprise 48 of the population they only
generate 12.2 percent of the business
Revenue in the state and under every
analysis that we have seen it will take
100 years to close that Gap given the
current process that you have in place
you served four years in the Senate
eight years of Secretary of State in
charge of businesses you served four
years as Governor what are your concrete
specific targeted plans to decrease and
address the racial Equity Gap currently
facing Contracting and purchasing for
minority-owned businesses Governor Kim
well I would remind Jordan's that the
first part of my plan was keeping our
state open for business and allowing all
business people and work in Jordans to
work when Stacey Abrams was criticizing
me for doing that also pushing to get
our kids back in the classroom when
again Stacey Abrams was criticizing me
for doing that a lot of Georgians
including African-Americans and other
minorities cannot go to work if their
kids are not in the classroom we have
the lowest unemployment rate in the
country for African Americans we also
were named the top we're in the top ten
of the states for black entrepreneurship
in the state of Georgia so our economy
is incredible and we will continue to
work with all of those entrepreneurs in
the days ahead and working class
Georgians because we are the ones that
have been fighting for you when Miss
Abrams was not so we were giving tax
refunds we were doing tax cuts we were
suspending the gas tax to help you deal
with 40-year high inflation when she was
criticizing us Stacey Abrams 30-second
rebuttal I would point out that Mr Kemp
did not address the needs of purchasing
in contracts for black and brown owned
businesses which is what he's refused to
do for the last 16 years we know that
10.9 billion dollars has been delivered
to the state of Georgia through two
recent acts at the Congressional level
and Brian Kemp does not have a plan plan
for making certain that people of color
have access to those contracts access to
purchasing it was only in July of this
year that he finally acknowledged that
there might be a problem he has said
that we need to study it I would tell
him just cheat off of my paper I know
the answer we need a governor who
actually believes in equity racial
Equity economic equity in the state of
Georgia and I will deliver thank you
Shane Hazel please ask your question to
Brian Kemp Brian in 2020 on April 2nd
you locked down Georgia threatening
peaceful people with force and coercion
you called people in Georgia
non-essential and it killed millions of
jobs
you bet the need a big Pharma and pushed
a vaccine that was untested on people
and it has killed people they have lost
their loved ones you've allowed
bureaucracy to invade our businesses and
then you had the audacity to brag about
record text revenue
you want to say sorry to anybody
so is that a question or that is a
question do you want to say sorry to
anybody well look I'll be glad to talk
about my record because obviously Mr
Hazel is gravely mistaken if you look at
the executive orders that I signed we
said every business in Georgia was
essential there was a few that we asked
to help us stop the spread flatten the
curve Bill PPE supplies in hospital bed
capacities because unlike him I was
getting the calls from hospitals saying
hey we are out of surgical gowns we're
out of mass we need ventilators and we
were literally working 24 7 to supply
those items while also keeping our
economy open in this state and as you
know I was the first state to open the
small parts that we asked to close and
our recovery has been as good as any
state in the country we have had two
record years of Economic Development
because of our business environment
working with the general assembly to
make sure that we're putting Jordans
first and Georgia businesses in Georgia
his last thing was how how great he did
by keeping everything open and now he's
like I mean it's crazy you should have
put Georgia Freedom First Period you
didn't have the power to lock down
businesses and you saw in the executive
order on April 2nd it was clear as day I
sat there and watched you do it I was
like there is no coming back from this
the idea that the the I guess the
default was to lock down Georgia instead
of trusting Georgians with their freedom
to adapt in a time of very changing
circumstances I think is a tyrant move
and I think the left and right are
fascists and communist socialists
whereas we're talking about real Liberty
trusting Georgians with those decisions
thank you Mr Hazel Brian Kemp you
imagine this guy debating Herschel
Walker for Shane Hazel well I would just
uh ask Mr Hazel if he supports the
things that we have done because we were
open and Georgians were working and
we've had excess Revenue so instead of
doing big government that's our tax
money okay yeah no I don't support it
because here's the thing is when when we
get to that point when we talk about
what you're doing okay finish your
question please go ahead I would just
say do you support the tax cuts we've
done returning a billion dollars of
taxpayer money and suspending the gas
tax for Jordans to help fight through
40-year high inflation and bad domestic
energy policy Georgia I hope you hear me
when I say Libertarians think taxation
is theft it's your money it's your
property you should be able to determine
what you do with it I don't support the
fact that you haven't ended qualified
immunity I don't support the fact that
you haven't ended civil asset forfeiture
I don't support the fact that you
haven't ended the drug war you haven't
ended non-violent crime you hadn't ended
cash bail you haven't ended no knock
Reds you haven't implemented Community
rewards and you haven't Bland banned
blacked out cop cars that go after
people for more they say community
urea boards should buy the executive to
leave peaceful people alone in the state
of Georgia that's my message to both of
you to everybody in the state who wears
a badge stop going after peaceful people
Mr Kemp 30 second rebuttal well that's
simply not true as Georgians know I had
followed the laws in the constitution of
this state and I ran after on going
after criminal street gangs because I
knew there was an issue in our state
when other people wouldn't even talk
about it in the media wouldn't everybody
who's here should get equal time but
what sucks is that this the the
libertarian guy has no shot and I really
want to hear from Stacey Abrams go back
and her going back and forth with Kemp
is what we would learn from I'm gonna go
after bad people that are selling bad
drugs and killing our children and our
other citizens a free market way to do
that would be to allow cannabis and
psilocybin to handle the mental health
issues okay
stop busting them then gentlemen we're
going to move on that concludes our
second round for those just joining us
this is the general election debate
between candidates for Governor we will
now go back to the panel to ask
questions to the candidate of their
choice until we run out of time as a
point of moderator privilege I may also
ask questions of the candidates and I
will determine when a rebuttal is
appropriate and I'm going to use that
moderator privilege right away to ask
some education questions Mr Kemp if
re-elected you've said you'll push for
65 million dollars dedicated to finding
pandemic learning loss more hiring more
counselors and recruiting teachers to
fill shortages how do you respond to
those who say you should have
prioritized those academic related
issues over laws dealing with divisive
Concepts parental laws and obscene books
in the past legislative session even
those who were pushed and pushing for
those laws in the end say they don't
have much teeth well look we have been
pushing for those things you can talk to
school superintendents around the state
we have worked with them really over the
last year and a half two years on
learning loss we've been working with
our superintendents and other education
groups we've passed two different pieces
of legislation dealing with the teacher
pipeline which is getting more teachers
into the system our plan has uh is
working with higher education including
our hbcus and others to make sure we're
getting more of the right people and and
more of them in the classroom to help
Mentor our children this is really just
the next step in the process we are
funding K-12 education in this state
more than we ever have per pupil ever
and that's coming off a recession during
the middle of a global pandemic this
includes my promised teacher pay raise
of five thousand dollars that we
completed in my first full term despite
having to deal with two years of a
global pandemic and a recession so I
think it's incredible what we've been
doing but make no mistake we have more
work to do and I'm committed to doing
that thank you Shane Hazel would you
tell us your education plan
yeah it's to put it in the hands of the
private sector the government education
that came from Prussia in the 1700s has
obviously failed the Americans we don't
understand economics we don't understand
our civil culture we don't understand
this guy's a parody of himself he's on
behind the scenes in in politics the the
idea that we want to privatize
everything as Libertarians is good for
Education think about Walmart having a
monopoly on Force to teach your children
it's insane the idea that we do this
with a government has side effects it's
we see them how is it a monopoly when
private schools charter schools and
homeschooling exist our parents to seek
out the best education for their kids
and we also believe that they have the
responsibility to do so so to help fix
this nation start here in Georgia is get
the government and the admin out of the
classroom and get it out of our Lives
thank you Miss Abrams in education you
propose a boost in Teachers Pay more
State paid preschool slots for lower
income children and their families and
more if you win the governor's race
you'll likely have Republican majorities
in both Chambers given what we know
about part of partisan divisions how
will you get your education proposals
passed and funded so let's begin with
what my proposals are George is sitting
on a 6.6 billion dollar Surplus that's
money that we have after we've paid
every bill after we put 15 aside for a
rainy day fund that is money that after
we've accounted for increases in
population and I want to invest it in
our children and in our families
beginning with making certain that we
have Pre-K slots we have four-year-olds
on a waiting list I've never met a
four-year-old who waits to turn five but
we can solve that problem with the money
we have right now we can also give an 11
000 pay raise to our teachers instead of
a five thousand dollar pay raise on
layaway we can make certain that we are
increasing access to the pipeline
because teachers aren't in the pipeline
because they can't make enough money to
take care of themselves in their fam
families and that is why under this
Governor we have a 67 retention rate any
other CEO who lost more than 30 percent
of their Workforce would be fired and
that is why my plan is to use the
resources we have today to plan for
today and tomorrow we've got the money
and we have economists in Georgia and
National economists who have looked at
my plan and they say it works check my
plan out at Stacey abrams.com check my
map it works thank you 30 seconds yeah
I'd just like to let people know that
look my plan is to use the revenue that
we have because we've been open if
Stacey Abrams have been your Governor
over the last four years you wouldn't
have that excess Revenue because she
wanted the state to stay locked down and
criticize me when I opened it back up we
have in fact been using this revenue and
will do so in the future to do another
income tax refund and put the money back
in your pocket we're also going to do a
property tax relief Grant one time that
helps you with Rising property values
and Rising property taxes that the
counties are not not rolling back thank
you very much I may respond because 30
seconds this is going to go back and
forth between the Democrats or
Republicans if they keep our taxes
for 30 seconds for Mr Hazel we're not
going to be excluded from this I'm not
excluding you but I'm getting he did
refer to her so we are going to have her
speak first you're going to take money
in property from people that don't even
attend your schools
we want to move on Miss Abrams I want to
point out three things that were
inaccurate one I urged caution because
any leader should privilege the lives of
those they serve 38 000 people died in
Georgia we have one County where one in
every 100 Hancock County very
libertarian whoever talks louder and
steamrolls everyone gets to speak but
they also urge good math we have the
money in our accounts to do what is
right money not delivered by Brian Kemp
money delivered by federal Democrats and
money that is delivered by hard-working
Georgians who have generated the Surplus
and they deserve investments in their
lives and the income taxes that we keep
hearing about 50 000 people were getting
half a billion dollars the rest of us
are going to see 193 bucks thank you
that is not a good return Jane Hazel 30
seconds please
all of its stolen money from people who
have property the fact we have property
tax in America has got to be one of the
most Un-American things I've ever heard
of there are a lot of us at home school
because we don't believe in the
government school he's a homeschooling
anti-vax taxes or slavery libertarian
get the hell out of here dude to pay for
a broken school system that we don't
agree with that's both of you guys hold
on sorry with all due respect Miss
Abrams called me out again all right
about these 30 seconds and then we
really are going to move on but the
federal money that we're able to use
right now and spend is because our state
was open and we didn't have to use this
Federal money to backfill State revenues
which has put us in an incredible
position uh to move forward in our state
several States
we're going to move on a gentlemen and
and Miss Abrams Greg Bluestein you have
the next question Miss Abrams I want to
go back to one of Donna's underlying
questions which is the how issue
absolutely you've staked out dozens of
policy proposals that would have to win
approval from lawmakers including
Medicaid expansion including several of
the proposals you outlined here today
but it's highly likely the legislature
will remain in Republican control how
are you going to win approval of these
measures uh when in the face of staunch
Republican opposition well I don't
actually believe there is staunch
Republican opposition I served in the
legislature for 11 years and every day
during my tenure I worked across the
aisle to get good done they put it in my
title I was minority leader meaning I
couldn't win unless I could work with
others that is why I'm the only person I
know who got an A rating from the
Georgia Chamber of Commerce and the
friend of Labor award for the same work
in the same year the work that I do is
working with people to find out how we
get Solutions Medicaid expansion is a
perfect example we have 19 hospitals at
risk of closure joining the six
hospitals that have closed under this
Governor we are sending a Brinks truck
of 3.5 billion dollars of our money to
Kentucky to Louisiana to Ohio because
this Governor will not accept the money
and the resources that we need in our
state will come to our state when we
have leaders willing to work across the
aisle to bring our money home but it's
more important than that it's about how
do we take care of our families how do
we make certain that we're addressing
High housing prices how do we tackle the
issue of gun violence how do we support
our freedoms and protect our people and
we need a governor who can do the math
but also do the morality of making sure
we take care of every single job thank
you Miss Abrams Governor Kemp you have
30 seconds well I would just say that
one way we deal with gun violence is to
take the bad people that are doing the
shootings and lock them up and not in
cash bail like Miss Abrams wants to do
but listen she's also said that the
silver bullet on health Care's Medicaid
expense and adding 600 650 000 people
well there's been six hundred thousand
people added to the Medicaid roll since
I become governor and the problem is
it's a broken government program that
she wants the government decide your
health care that will also kick 200 000
private citizens off their private
sector Health Care thank you Thirty
second rebuttal just talk about that
called her name Miss Abrams you have a
30 second rebuttal this is ridiculous
number one Medicaid expansion will allow
500 000 Georgians who are working people
to get access to health care that is a
good thing in a state where we have
people dying every day from cancer from
issues with health issues with diabetes
issues with heart disease but number two
the six hundred thousand people he
references who are on Medicaid they are
put there because of the public health
emergency and when that ends they will
lose health care which will add more
people who are on the streets unable to
get health care under this Governor
we've lost six hospitals we have
ambulance wait times that are excessive
and
the Democrats have controlled the U.S
Senate for two years because Georgia
shifted from two Republicans to two
Democrats in January of 2021. one of
those seats was held by Kelly Lefler a
person you appointed to that post she
then lost to Senator Warnock do you wish
you had made a different Choice when you
were selected Kelly Leffler well no not
at all I mean I've I was excited about
her candidacy I know she worked
extremely hard it was a very challenging
environment in 2020 and I think it goes
to the point that in 2020 watching that
election I learned a lot of lessons you
know a lot of the things that we haven't
been doing with the ground game from a
political perspective we are now doing
making sure that when we're campaigning
that we're making sure what we know the
differences are with the candidates but
also we got to be for something and what
I'm for is doing another billion dollar
tax rebate for doing property tax relief
grants for continuing to strengthen
rural Georgia and run rural broadband
like we have been doing that we started
this program long before the pandemic
hit doing Economic Development projects
where 74 percent of the investment of
over 30 billion dollars over the last
two record years is going to rural
Georgia over half the
you know 80 000 jobs that are going with
those projects outside the 10 Metro
counties in rural Georgia and I'm
committed to doing that in the future Mr
Hazel if you would like to have 30
seconds you make thank you very much the
the state of Georgia needs a governor
who understands econ the 200 trillion
dollars of unfunded liability in this
country as a veteran understanding that
we have a veterans Health Care system
that is in shambles they treat you as a
liability and they will throw pills at
you every chance they get they won't
actually address your health there is no
way on Earth we're going to expand that
to the rest of the 99 of the country
it's a fairy tale and it doesn't exist
that's why the economy is collapsing
because they continue to print trillions
and trillions of dollars and Hike
interest rates at the same time by what
metric is the economy collapsing learn
to ask a question this question is for
each of you what do you see as the
biggest challenge facing Georgia and
Georgians and how do you think it should
be addressed what will you do as webinar
to address that challenge let's start
with you Stacy Abrams
gang crime is up gun violence is up
housing prices have skyrocketed Equity
investors have purchased 30 percent of
the homes in the state of Georgia we
have 1.4 million people without health
insurance who cannot see a doctor when
they need one we live in a state of fear
and this is a governor who's for the
last four years has beat his chest but
delivered very little for most Georgians
he has weakened gun laws and flooded our
streets he has weakened our privacy
rights and our and women's rights he has
denied women the access to reproductive
care the most dangerous thing facing
Georgia is four more years of Brian Kemp
we need a governor who actually
understands the math and the morality we
need to understand that yes we have
veterans like Mr Hazel pointed out who
can't get access to health care in part
because they're not fully covered by VA
benefits and will only get health
insurance if we expand Medicaid we have
seniors who are being forced out of
their homes because this Governor
refuses to address the issue of housing
crises in fact he told an audience that
he didn't want to upset investors by
giving local local
authorities control over housing prices
letting them address the issues we need
a governor I want to
give each one of them a chance to answer
the Jennifer's question Shane Hazel
the biggest problem facing us is the
economy but to quote uh the great
rothbard the man who puts all the guns
and all the decision-making power into
the hands of a central government and
then says limit yourself is he truly the
Impractical you in utopian the idea that
the economy isn't the biggest problem
that we have in Georgia is because
people don't understand economics these
guys don't understand economics from
Republicans Or democrats or else we
wouldn't be in the hole that we're in in
terms of trillions and trillions of
dollars what we need to do is get back
to basics Austrian economics where we
get rid of this cancer that is invaded
every transaction that we have through a
fiat currency system creating freedom
for everybody in Georgia is the default
position not more government not more
programs not more policies not more
point at the barrel of a gun force and
coercion it is freedom all right Brian
Kemp your answer to the question well
I'll first since I didn't get a rebuttal
after being called out would just let
Jordan us know again that my records
being attacked because Miss Abrams
doesn't want to talk about her own
record if you look at what the state of
Georgia and our first lady Marty Kemp
has done to raise the awareness on
ending human trafficking going after the
perpetrators and supporting the victim
as well as us working with the general
assembly to give Medicaid benefits to
new to birthing mothers up to a year
after having that child and other things
shows you or state that we value life
and that we care but in the future my
focus is going to be what it was when I
opened the debate and that is helping
you fight through 40-year high inflation
and disastrous policies in Washington
D.C I would remind you that Stacey
Abrams campaign to be Joe Biden's
running mate she supports these policies
that have raised taxes on hard-working
Americans in Georgians when they
promised they would not we're working
with the general assembly to help you
fight through that by suspending the gas
tax and giving your money back thank you
thank you very much Greg your next
question I want to stay with you um and
talk about something that just came up
with the last exchange a little bit
earlier today you rolled out a new
Public Safety plan that offers a
Crackdown promotes a Crackdown on
criminal offenses but it doesn't
specifically address is gun violence
your critics say that your permissive
gun policies will only lead to more
crime what do you propose you will do in
a second term if you're re-elected to
address gun related crimes nothing well
again we're we're going after the people
that are doing these crimes I mean and
that's what we're doing going after uh
street gangs in this regard you know
during the pandemic when I was talking
to people about how we respond and what
we were dealing with I was hearing from
Educators and athletic directors and
other people saying governor we got to
get our kids back in the classroom
because we're losing them we're going to
lose them a decade of children because
these kids that we're recruiting when
they're 13 14 15 year old years old to
be on the ball field or be in the band
or be on the robotics team or what have
the extracurricular activity they're
being recruited by street gangs because
they're not in the classroom so those
are the kind of things that we are
focused on to make sure that these kids
are under the right environment and my
new Public Safety plan is stiffening
pills penalties for gang gang members
that are recruiting our children and I
believe that most Jordans support that
and I'm committed to working with all
law enforcement to make a dent there
thank you Chuck Williams this is for
governor Kemp and Miss Abrams Columbus
Macon Atlanta and other communities have
benefited from a Georgia State Patrol
task force that has helped augment
police coverage in those cities and some
others over the last year what can be
done to make sure that local agencies
agencies that are short on officers can
handle these police policing duties
without having to rely on the state
yeah look I'm glad that uh answered that
question the crime suppressing unit that
I asked Colonel Wright to put together
during civil unrest when I grew tired of
local elected political leaders that
wouldn't let their local law enforcement
go after dangerous people during civil
unrest that had no chase policies where
Street Racers and street gangs are
terrorizing our citizens I told Colonel
Wright I wanted to plan I wanted to know
how much it's going to cost and I want
to know who we're going to work with and
that's why the state patrol gbi
Department of Natural Resources game
wardens working with Fulton County
Sheriff Who's helped us with jail
facilities the Atlanta Police Department
we wouldn't put a plan together to start
going after Street Racers and going
after violent criminals and have more
boots on the ground we've done the same
thing in Columbus we've done it in
making we've done it in Savannah and
we'll do it wherever we're needed this
is not our job we're using funds from
the governors of emergency
a fund to help pay for these dollars and
thankfully the general assembly supports
that because we've been in the fight
when others were not thank you Miss
Abrams kind of a word salad of buzzwords
to shoot six Asian women going into a
gun store getting a weapon and murdering
women in less than an hour street gangs
aren't the reason people are getting
shot in grocery stores and in parking
lots and at schools street gangs are one
part of the problem but we have a
governor who's weakened gun laws across
the state flooded our streets with Guns
by letting dangerous people get access
to those weapons Georgia does not have a
waiting period we do not have Universal
background checks and one of the few
permits that we had that was helping
Keep Us Safe stopped five thousand
people who should not have had weapons
from getting them got weakened by this
governor with his criminal carry law as
the next Governor my intention would be
to actually give the people who do
ninety percent of law enforcement the
support they need we know that they have
asked for at least 136 million dollars
so they can recruit and retain officers
I am the only candidate who's put in
place a plan for at least 25 million
dollars in Grants not loans to go to
these local Law Enforcement Officers so
they can recruit and retain officers so
that their officers aren't working two
or three jobs simply to make ends meet
thank you before your rebuttal Governor
Kemp Shane Hazel you may respond to this
question you keep going back to God and
Stacy and I think it's going to be your
undoing here in Georgia Georgia we're
going to have less and less gun laws
whether it's under Republicans few or
Libertarians Libertarians don't believe
in any gun laws we believe that you know
how to best protect you and your
property and the biggest mass murder in
history is government it's not private
citizens most private citizens like I
said before go throughout their day
without doing any harm to anybody
however the people in the government
with all the guns still go after people
with a badge when they shouldn't have to
in Holly Springs Georgia I introduced
the Helios initiative where we got rid
of civil asset forfeiture it was a
one-page bill through decentralization
nullification using the Constitution
that made the office officers in Holly
Springs safer because they don't have to
go out there and they don't have to
harass people of color while driving
while black they don't have to go out
there and look for drug color like you
miss Abrams because civil asset
forfeiture is also the government
stealing more than criminals hardened
criminals from anybody and everybody in
the state of Georgia Thank You Governor
Kemp 30 seconds well thank you I would
just let people at home know the largest
fastest growing segment of the
population that's buying handguns and
Firearms is African Americans and
females you know why because the
criminals are the only ones that do have
the guns you have local governments that
are holding up is he saying the
criminals are all white men law-abiding
citizens from being being able to to
Simply use their Second Amendment right
to protect themselves and their property
and their families I will certainly
support that thank you Mr Hazel May I
respond yes 30 seconds
let's be clear I believe that we can
protect the Second Amendment and protect
second graders at the exact same time
that means that yes more people are
buying guns but that's because they
think that's the only way to protect
themselves because guns have flooded our
streets these are communities that want
to be safe they don't want to have to
carry weapons I know how to shoot my
great-grandmother taught me but I know
that the person who is most responsible
is the person who holds the weapon and
that is why I will quote Ronald Reagan
trust but verify and because of the
criminal carry law that Brian Kemp
signed into law there is no longer a
background check the moderators sort of
like reluctantly let people speak did
you see how the moderate was just like
okay 30 seconds I'm gonna take the guns
I really want to move on well there
there is a 30 second background check
there's a federal background check on
every individual that buys a firearm in
the United States Over America shouldn't
exist either well the point that's not
true I understand the the point you're
making but the point is when you buy 5
firearm you get a background check none
of the laws were changed Mr Kemp if you
purchased a weapon in Georgia through a
gun sale or a private sale
candidates
I'm going to allow Jennifer to ask
what's going to be the final question in
this round oh my God a study recently
showed frustration among our Nations
teachers with political interference
into education with issues like covid-19
and critical race Theory presenting
additional challenges to a profession
that's already dealing with low pay
falling interest and people leaving what
would you do specifically as Governor to
recruit retain and Empower Educators for
schools across the state of Georgia for
each of you
all right we'll start with you miss
Abrams and let me again again apologize
to Mr Kim for interrupting this is a
very important topic to me and I
apologize for my Outburst I will say
that when it comes he's too polite and
we know teachers are leaving the
workforce
we have a 67 retention rate but 70 of
our teachers have said they would not
recommend teaching to their colleagues
that is because of low pay because of
over regulation because of high stress
and because they believe that they are
being told to teach to a curriculum that
does not reflect the values and needs of
our students when a teacher is told that
you have to lie to a child which is what
happened with the divisive language the
divisive Concepts legislation teachers
are not being able to teach the whole
history of our students they're not able
to tell their children what they need to
know as the next governor of Georgia I
will repeal those laws I will increase
pay and I will make certain that all of
our teachers can start and continue
through their time thank you and well
protected and well will anyone use the
Trump line on this issue no teachers
should ever be allowed
transgender I would just say this is
exactly why I did the five thousand
dollar teacher pay raise that I ran on
in 2018
we've also done a parent's Bill of
Rights to have parents fully engaged
with their schools to make sure that
they know what's happening their kids
quite honestly people are tired of their
kids being indoctrinated in the
classroom right but we've also worked
with our Educators on these pieces of
legislation to make sure that they make
good common sense it's a piece off but I
would also tell you that people are
tired of these issues like not having
fairness in girls Sports and other
things and quite honestly it's woken a
lot of people up so we got to continue
to have good conversations like we've
done with our teacher pipeline
legislation like we're doing with
helping 9 000 pair Pros get fully
certified that's a major issue
boys and girls Sports 25 seconds your
question raises a lot of interesting
points a lot of these teachers like my
own wife has left the profession of
teaching to homeschool have to go to
private schools teachers do something
outside of this narrative where admin
from the federal government and the
state government is forcing them to
teach things they don't want to teach to
teach to test they can't stand the
administration who makes six figures
that is bloated it is absolutely gotten
out of control we need to nullify
property tax we need to let people get
out of this system we need to allow the
private sector to work because before
education was put under the thumb of
government here we had some of the
brightest most well-read people in the
entire world and that's what we need to
bring back all right thank you very much
we are running out of time so that is
all the time we have for questions each
candidate will now have only 40 seconds
for a closing statement Brian Kemp you
get the first closing statement well
first of all let me thank the Atlanta
Press Club for having us when I I ran
for governor in 2018 I promised to put
hard work in georgian's first ahead of
the status quo and the politically
correct I think I said shortly after
being sworn in I would work hard as your
Governor every single day for all
Georgians whether you voted for me or
not I'm so optimistic about the future
of our state the lowest unemployment
rate in the history of the state the
most people working in Economic
Opportunity in all parts of our state no
matter your ZIP code or neighborhood
Stacy Abrams said George is the worst
state in the country to live well Marty
the girls and I disagree we think
Georgia is the greatest state in the
country to live work and raise our
children and that's why I'm asking for
your vote and support to keep it that
way thank you and God bless thank you
Stacey Abrams 40 seconds I too want to
thank everyone tonight for your support
and I want to point out that Brian Kemp
did make promises he promised to keep us
safe but crime has gone up he promised
to protect us and yet he's attacked our
freedoms he has promised to take care of
our families and yet the rising prices
in Georgia are rising because he refuses
to expand Medicaid because he refuses to
tackle the affordable housing crisis
that we have and he's sitting on 400
million dollars of our money that he
will not spend to keep us under roofs
and in our homes as the next Governor I
want us to have more more money in our
pockets more protections and our lives
more freedoms in our days and more
opportunity in our communities I see all
of Georgia and as the next Governor it
would be my intention to serve all of
Georgia I encourage you to go to my
website Stacey abrams.com and please
make a plan to vote and know that I'm
asking for your vote tonight thank you
Shane Hazel you get the final 42nd
closing statement Georgia you are
essential we are in Changing Times
technology money politics are all
changing incredibly fast as humans our
superpower is our ability to adapt to a
changing world this power to adapt our
passion and genius is Unleashed when it
is free this is cringe
free from tax free from government and
their lockdowns free from government
mandates and free from force and
coercion
you know best how to adapt and run your
life and that is your right to do so it
is time peaceful people were free to
take on the challenges we Face our
message to the government is simple it's
time to be peaceful people alone if you
believe the government is so damn
essential we have to go I'm sorry
that concludes our debate we'd like to
remind voters that election day is
Tuesday November 8th and early voting
has already begun our thanks to the
candidates panel of journalists would
also like to thank the Atlanta Press
Club for arranging today's debate for
more information about the debates they
will host this election season visit
atlantapressclub.org debates I'm Donna
Lowry thanks for joining us for the
Atlanta Press Club debates
what a disaster let's see the Dynamics
and see if anybody shakes hands or if
the libertarian guy keeps shaking his
head or what goes on they're not going
to show us so listen
um one of the things that happens in
these debates is that the the format
gets in the way of debate everybody
agrees to 30 seconds this 40 seconds
that
they become so rigidly attached to it
that then there's no actual debate
um and you need a format I'm not denying
that but you can actually include I mean
listen if they could be adults you could
come in and say Hey listen we'll have
these five minute periods for kind of
free exchange but you cannot talk over
each other you talk over each other and
we just shut it down okay and we we
start muting mics to the extent that you
all can actually talk to each other like
adults we will allow these you know
whatever periods can they behave like
adults I don't really know so that's
number one secondly an hour is tough
particularly with three candidates you
probably should have at least 75 minutes
for two candidates you probably need at
least 90 minutes put a five minute break
in the middle if you need to do that
um and then there's also this issue of
you know on the one hand of course I'm
for third parties and on and on and on
we're also two weeks before the election
and libertarian dude is cuckoo for Coco
Puffs and has no chance and interrupts
everyone where I really want to hear
Abrams and Kemp talk about issues so you
know you need to figure out some way to
deal with that
um
I don't know listen bottom line
Stacy Abrams is brilliant I think she's
awesome
um she's down five right now uh in fact
we can look at the latest polling here
she's down five let's see if there's
been any new polls now still down five
to Brian Kemp if you live in Georgia
you've got a lot on your hands because
on the one hand you've got the Walker
Warnock race very important and you've
also got this gubernatorial race so
we're going to be looking very very very
strongly at all of it I want to say a
huge thank you to the gifter to end all
gifters s Prez who just gifted 74
subscriptions on Twitch putting us at
our goal of 100 thanks to that oh and
you know what Jason sickmeyer just
gifted one putting us at 101. on that
note I will see everybody tomorrow
tomorrow as they say
um for the what what debate is tomorrow
oh tomorrow is um the guy with the
little hands what's his name Marco Rubio
Little Marco Marco Rubio and Val demings
that's tomorrow evening if you're
watching on Twitch let's raid Gotham
chess our friend Levy who we have not
raided for a while I think it is going
to be a beautiful thing and I will see
everybody else tomorrow